ברוכים הבאים חזרה להבנת מידע קוונטי וחישוב קוונטי שמי John Watus ואני המנהל הטכני לחינוך ב-IBM Quantum
זה השיעור ה-13 בסדרה וזה השיעור הראשון ביחידה הרביעית והאחרונה שעוסקת בתיקון שגיאות
קוונטי לחישוב קוונטי יש פוטנציאל לאפשר פתרונות יעילים למשימות חישוביות שעבורן
אלגוריתמים קלאסיים יעילים לא ידועים ואולי לא קיימים אבל יש אתגרים מאוד משמעותיים ש
צריך יהיה להתגבר עליהם אם נרצה ליישם את סוגי החישובים הקוונטיים בקנה מידה גדול שאנחנו מקווים שיום אחד יהיו
אפשריים לב העניין הוא שמידע קוונטי הוא שברירי מאוד אפשר פשוט להרוס אותו רק על ידי
הסתכלות עליו ולכן כדי לפעול נכון מחשבים קוונטיים צריכים לבודד את המידע הקוונטי שהם
מאחסנים מהסביבה סביבם לרמה קיצונית אבל באותו זמן המחשב הקוונטי עצמו חייב לספק לנו
שליטה מדויקת מאוד על המידע הקוונטי הזה וזה כולל אתחול נכון פעולות יוניטריות מדויקות ואמינות
וכמובן היכולת לבצע מדידות כדי שנוכל באמת לקבל את התוצאות של
החישוב יש ברור מתח בין הדרישות האלה ובימים הראשונים של חישוב קוונטי היו כאלה שחשבו שהשבריריות
של מידע קוונטי והרגישות שלו גם לאי-דיוקים וגם לרעש סביבתי בסופו של דבר
יהפכו חישוב קוונטי לבלתי אפשרי היום אין ספק שבניית מחשב קוונטי מדויק ואמין
בקנה מידה גדול הוא אתגר עצום אבל יש לנו כלי מפתח שעוזר לנו במאמץ הזה שגורם לרוב
האנשים שמבינים בתחום להיות אופטימיים לגבי חישוב קוונטי בקנה מידה גדול שיום אחד יהפוך למציאות והכלי הזה הוא תיקון שגיאות
קוונטי בארבעת השיעורים הבאים נדון בתיקון שגיאות קוונטי עם דגש על
היסודות בשיעור הזה ניקח מבט ראשון על תיקון שגיאות קוונטי כולל אחד מהקודים הקוונטיים הראשונים לתיקון
שגיאות שהתגלו קוד ה-9 qubit של Shore ונדון גם במושג יסודי נוסף בתיקון שגיאות
קוונטי שנקרא דיסקרטיזציה של שגיאות בשיעורים הבאים ביחידה נראה קודים מתוחכמים יותר ובסופו של דבר טובים יותר
לתיקון שגיאות קוונטיות ונדון גם בבעיה של חישוב קוונטי על מידע קוונטי מקודד באמצעות
רכיבי חישוב שהם בעצמם לא מושלמים ונוטים לשגיאות הנה סקירה קצרה של
השיעור נתחיל בדיון בקודי חזרה קלאסיים שהם אולי הסוג הפשוט והבסיסי ביותר
של קוד קלאסי לתיקון שגיאות קודי חזרה קלאסיים הם לא קודים טובים במיוחד לפי סטנדרטים של תורת
קידוד קלאסית לפחות בפני עצמם אבל זה בסדר כאן אנחנו הולכים על פשטות ובפרט
נסתכל על כמעט הקוד הקלאסי הפשוט ביותר לתיקון שגיאות שאפשר לדמיין שאותו נשתמש אחר כך כבסיס לדוגמה פשוטה
של קוד קוונטי לתיקון שגיאות הדוגמה הזו היא קוד ה-9 qubit של Shore שנדון בו בפירוט
כולל תיאור של הקוד עצמו וכן הליכים לקידוד qubit-ים באמצעות הקוד הזה זיהוי שגיאות ב-qubit-ים מקודדים ו
תיקון השגיאות האלה ובחלק השלישי של השיעור נדון בדיסקרטיזציה של שגיאות שמאפשרת לנו לחשוב על שגיאות שרירותיות על
qubit-ים שבעיקרון יוצרות רצף של אפשרויות במונחים דיסקרטיים בעיקרון מזקקות שגיאות ל
מה שנקרא היפוכי ביט והיפוכי פאזה לפני שנכנס לפרטים הטכניים של תיקון שגיאות קוונטי כדאי
לקחת רגע לשקול את הצורך בתיקון שגיאות קוונטי וכן תיקון שגיאות
קלאסי כפי שרמזתי בתחילת השיעור מחשבים קוונטיים רגישים מאוד לשגיאות בגלל
השבריריות של מידע קוונטי בפרט אינטראקציות לא רצויות עם הסביבה או במילים
אחרות שאר העולם יכולות להפריע למידע קוונטי האינטראקציות הלא רצויות האלה יכולות לגרום לדה-קוהרנס כאשר מידע
בעצם דולף אל הסביבה וגורם למידע שמאוחסן במחשב הקוונטי להתנהג יותר ויותר
באופן קלאסי גם חשוב מאוד שנכיר בכך שפעולות קוונטיות ניתנות לביצוע רק בדיוק
מוגבל למשל אולי נרצה לבצע gate קוונטי מסוים על qubit אבל מכיוון שהתקנים פיזיים
אף פעם לא מושלמים מה שאנחנו בפועל מיישמים עשוי להיות רק קירוב ל-gate הזה זה אולי לא משנה הרבה עבור
gate בודד אבל אם הכוונה שלנו היא לבצע אלפים או מיליוני gate-ים קוונטיים אי הדיוקים הקטנים האלה
יתחילו להצטבר וכשהחישוב יסתיים אנחנו עלולים לקבל מצב שונה מאוד ממה ש
ציפינו אז זה מקור שונה למדי לשגיאות אבל זה בהחלט מקור שאי אפשר
להתעלם ממנו אנשים חוקרים קודים קלאסיים לתיקון שגיאות כבר קרוב למאה שנה ולקודים האלה יש יישומים רבים כולל ב
העברת מידע ואחסון אבל מכיוון שרכיבי חישוב קלאסיים כל כך אמינים אנחנו בעצם לא
צריכים תיקון שגיאות כדי לבנות מחשבים קלאסיים עכשיו ייתכן שתיקון שגיאות לא באמת נדרש
כדי לבנות מחשבים קוונטיים אמינים בקנה מידה גדול למשל הרעיון המרכזי מאחורי חישוב קוונטי
טופולוגי הוא שאולי אפשר לבנות מערכות קוונטיות חסינות שמוגנות מטבען מפני רעש בגלל
תכונות טופולוגיות של המערכות אבל אנחנו לא יודעים אם זה יהיה אפשרי ויש אמונה רחבה למדי
שתיקון שגיאות כנראה יהיה הכרחי בצורה כזו או אחרת לחישוב קוונטי בקנה מידה גדול עכשיו נדון בקודי
חזרה קלאסיים שמהווים את הבסיס לקוד הקוונטי הראשון שלנו לתיקון שגיאות קוד ה-9 qubit של Shore ש
נראה בקרוב קודי חזרה הם דוגמאות בסיסיות ביותר של קודים לתיקון שגיאות
הרעיון הוא שאפשר להגן על ביטים מפני שגיאות על ידי חזרה פשוטה על כל ביט מספר פעמים בפרט בואו נסתכל על
קוד החזרה של שלושה ביטים כאן אנחנו מקודדים ביט אחד לשלושה על ידי חזרה פשוטה על הביט שלוש פעמים אז
אפס מקודד כ-000 ואחד מקודד כ-111 כמובן שאם שום דבר לא משתבש אנחנו
יכולים בקלות להבחין בין שתי האפשרויות אבל אם הייתה שגיאה ואחד מהביטים התהפך נגיד
כלומר שאפס הופך לאחד או אחד הופך לאפס אז עדיין אפשר להבין מה היה הביט המקורי
על ידי בדיקה איזה משני הערכים הבינאריים מופיע פעמיים באופן שקול אפשר לפענח על ידי חישוב ערך הרוב
או במילים אחרות הערך הבינארי שמופיע הכי הרבה ולא קשה לראות ש
אם יש לנו לכל היותר שגיאת היפוך ביט אחת אז הפענוח יהיה נכון כמובן שאם שני ביטים מתהפכים או אם
כל שלושת הביטים מתהפכים אז זה לא יעבוד ונקבל ערך שגוי כשנפענח וזו תכונה כללית
שיש לכל קוד לתיקון שגיאות אולי תוכל לתקן חלק מהשגיאות אבל לעולם לא תוכל לתקן כל שגיאה ובסופו של דבר מדובר
בהקטנת הסיכוי לשגיאה לעומת הבטחת נכונות שבדרך כלל לא
אפשרית כדוגמה למצב שבו אפשר להקטין את הסיכוי לטעות נניח שהמטרה
שלנו היא לתקשר ביט בודד למקבל היפותטי ולשם כך אנחנו יכולים לשדר ביטים דרך
מה שנקרא ערוץ בינארי סימטרי שמהפך כל ביט שעובר דרכו באופן בלתי תלוי עם הסתברות
P אז עם הסתברות 1 מינוס P המקבל יקבל את הביט שהתכוונו לשלוח אבל עם הסתברות P
הביט מתהפך והמקבל מקבל את הערך ההפוך ממה ששלחנו אז אם אנחנו לא משתמשים בקוד
החזרה ובמקום זאת פשוט שולחים את הביט שבראש שלנו דרך הערוץ המקבל יקבל ביט שגוי עם
הסתברות P מצד שני אם קודם מקודדים את הביט שרוצים לשלוח באמצעות קוד החזרה של שלושה ביטים ו
אז שולחים כל אחד משלושת הביטים של הקידוד דרך הערוץ אז כל אחד מהם מתהפך עם הסתברות P אז
הסיכוי להיפוך ביט עכשיו גדול יותר כי עכשיו יש שלושה ביטים שיכולים להתהפך במקום אחד
אבל אם לכל היותר אחד מהביטים מתהפך אז המקבל יוכל לפענח נכון אז נקבל שגיאה אחרי
פענוח רק אם שניים או יותר מהביטים מתהפכים בזמן השידור ולא קשה מדי לחשב שזה קורה עם
הסתברות 3 כפול P בריבוע מינוס 2 כפול P בשלישית עבור ערכים של P קטנים מ-1/2
זה מוביל לירידה בהסתברות שהמקבל יקבל ביט שגוי עדיין יהיה סיכוי לשגיאה במקרה הזה אבל
הקוד מקטין את הסבירות לזה ואם רוצים להקטין את הסיכוי עוד יותר אפשר לעשות את זה באמצעות
קוד אחר כולל אך לא רק האפשרות להשתמש בקוד חזרה שבו הביט המקודד חוזר על עצמו
יותר משלוש פעמים עבור ערכים של P גדולים מ-1/2 אגב הקוד בעצם מחמיר
את המצב במובן שהוא מגדיל את הסבירות שהמקבל יקבל ביט שגוי אז בהחלט לא נשתמש בקוד הזה במצב
כזה קוד החזרה של שלושה ביטים הוא קוד קלאסי לתיקון שגיאות אבל אפשר גם לבדוק מה קורה אם
מנסים להשתמש בו כדי להגן על qubit-ים מפני שגיאות הוא לא קוד קוונטי טוב במיוחד לתיקון שגיאות כפי שנראה הוא
יכול לתקן חלק מהשגיאות אבל הוא הופך שגיאות אחרות ליותר סבירות אבל הוא הצעד הראשון לקראת קוד
Shore אז בואו נראה איך הוא עובד עבור qubit-ים קודם כל להבהרה כשאנחנו מתייחסים לקוד החזרה של 3 ביטים בשימוש
עבור qubit-ים מה שיש לנו בראש זה קידוד של qubit כפי שמוצג על המסך כאשר אלפא 0 ועוד בטא 1
מקודד כאלפא 000 ועוד בטא 111 או במילים אחרות מצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי
חוזר שלוש פעמים שימו לב בפרט שזה לא אותו דבר כמו חזרה על המצב הקוונטי שלוש פעמים כמו במצב
קוונטי נתון s שמקודד כ-s טנזור s טנזור s וזה לא קידוד שנוכל
ליישם עבור מצב קוונטי לא ידוע s לפי משפט אי-השכפול הקידוד שאנחנו מדברים
עליו לעומת זאת ניתן ליישום בקלות רבה הנה circuit קוונטי מאוד פשוט שעושה את זה באמצעות שני qubit-ים מאותחלים כמרחב עבודה ושני
gate-ים מבוקרים NOT עכשיו נניח ששגיאה מתרחשת אחרי שהקידוד בוצע
ובפרט נניח שפעולת פאולי X או במילים אחרות היפוך ביט קורה על אחד
מה-qubit-ים ובאיור הזה זה ה-qubit האמצעי כמובן שזו לא הסוג היחיד של שגיאה שיכולה לקרות ואולי תתנגדו
לרעיון ששגיאה לוקחת צורה של פעולה יוניטרית מושלמת כזו אבל נחזור לזה מאוחר יותר בשיעור ולעכשיו אפשר
פשוט לחשוב על זה כדוגמה הנה המצב שמתקבל זה אותו דבר כמו הקידוד המקורי חוץ מזה
שהביט האמצעי בתוך כל קט התהפך ברור שאפשר לראות את זה מהביטויים המתמטיים של המצב
אבל נניח שהיו לנו רק את שלושת ה-qubit-ים ושחשדנו שאולי התרחש היפוך ביט אבל לא ידענו איזה qubit אולי
הושפע דרך אחת לגלות אם התרחש היפוך ביט היא לבצע מדידה בבסיס הסטנדרטי ולבדוק את התוצאה במקרה הזה היינו רואים
או 010 או 101 עם הסתברויות שתלויות באלפא ובטא ובכל מקרה המסקנה שלנו
הייתה שהביט האמצעי התהפך אבל לצערנו זה הורס את המצב הקוונטי המקורי והמצב
הזה עשוי להיות יקר לנו הרי כל העניין הוא להגן על המצב הקוונטי הזה אז זו לא אופציה
טובה מה שאפשר לעשות במקום זה הוא להשתמש ב-circuit הקוונטי שמוצג כאן על המסך שבו מזינים את המצב המקודד
לשלושת ה-qubit-ים העליונים בעיקרון מה שה-circuit עושה הוא לחשב את הזוגיות של מצבי
הבסיס הסטנדרטי עבור שני ה-qubit-ים העליונים וכן עבור שני ה-qubit-ים התחתונים של הקידוד וזה יחשוף את
המיקום של היפוך הביט בפרט במקרה הזה נקבל תוצאה אחד עבור שתי בדיקות הזוגיות ומ
המידע הזה אפשר להסיק שזה הביט האמצעי שנבדל מהשניים האחרים אז זה כנראה זה שהתהפך
ובאופן קריטי זה לא גורם למצב לקרוס אז עכשיו יש לנו הזדמנות לנסות לתקן את היפוך
הביט הזה כדי שבסופו של דבר נוכל אולי לפענח ולקבל את המצב המקורי שלנו בחזרה נחזור לתיקון
עוד רגע אבל קודם בואו נשקול בקצרה את האפשרויות האחרות לשגיאת היפוך ביט אם במקום זאת שגיאת היפוך הביט
התרחשה על ה-qubit התחתון או השמאלי אז נקבל תוצאה 10 בקריאה מלמטה למעלה ושוב
המצב לא ישתנה ואם היפוך הביט קרה ל-qubit העליון אז הפלט יהיה
01 ושוב המצב לא משתנה ואגב אם לא הייתה שגיאת
היפוך ביט בכלל אז תוצאת המדידה היא 00 ושוב המצב יוצא ללא שינוי
אז בואו נסכם את כל זה בצורת טבלה שבה אנחנו מפרטים כל אחד מהמצבים האפשריים שמתקבלים מלכל היותר היפוך ביט אחד תוצאות
המדידה שאנחנו מכנים סינדרום בהקשר של תיקון שגיאות והתיקון שצריך לעשות כדי לקבל חזרה את הקידוד
המקורי אם לא הייתה שגיאה הסינדרום הוא 00 ואין צורך לעשות שום דבר כדי לתקן את
המצב אם ה-qubit התחתון או השמאלי חווה היפוך ביט הסינדרום הוא 10 והתיקון המתאים
הוא להפעיל X gate על ה-qubit התחתון או השמאלי ושני המקרים האחרים הם
דומים אז אם מפעילים את התיקון המתאים על סמך הסינדרום אז נהיה בטוחים שנשחזר את הקידוד
המקורי בכל ארבעת המקרים שוב אנחנו מתייחסים רק לאפשרות שלכל היותר שגיאת היפוך ביט
אחת התרחשה זה לא היה עובד נכון אם שניים או שלושה ביטים היו מתהפכים ולא שקלנו גם את
האפשרות של שגיאות אחרות עכשיו בואו נשקול סוג אחר של שגיאה בהקשר הקוונטי שגיאות
היפוך ביט הן לא השגיאות היחידות שצריך לדאוג מהן למשל צריך גם לדאוג משגיאות היפוך
פאזה או בקיצור היפוכי פאזה שמתוארים על ידי Z gate-ים או באופן שקול פעולות פאולי Z
לצערנו קוד החזרה של שלושה ביטים נכשל לחלוטין בזיהוי היפוכי פאזה למשל נניח ש
מקודדים qubit באמצעות קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים בדיוק כמו קודם ושגיאת היפוך פאזה מתרחשת על ה-qubit
האמצעי נקבל את המצב שמוצג על המסך שהוא בדיוק הקידוד שהיינו מקבלים אם
היפוך פאזה היה קורה ל-qubit המקורי לפני שקידדנו ואז אם נבצע את אותו
circuit כמו קודם כדי לנסות לזהות שגיאה נקבל סינדרום 00 שמרמז בטעות שלא התרחשו שגיאות
אז קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים עובד עבור לכל היותר שגיאת היפוך ביט אחת אבל הוא נכשל בזיהוי שגיאות היפוך פאזה ב
עצם הוא מחמיר את המצב במובן מסוים כי עכשיו יש לנו פי שלוש יותר qubit-ים שעלולים לחוות שגיאות היפוך
פאזה ראינו שקוד החזרה של שלושה ביטים עיוור לחלוטין לשגיאות היפוך פאזה אז הוא לא נראה
מועיל במיוחד להתמודדות עם סוג כזה של שגיאה אבל בעצם אפשר לשנות את קוד החזרה של שלושה ביטים כך שהוא
כן יזהה שגיאות היפוך פאזה ואסביר עכשיו איך אפשר לעשות את זה הנה ה-circuit המקורי ל
קידוד qubit באמצעות קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים והדרך שבה נשנה אותו היא מאוד פשוטה פשוט מפעילים
Hadamard gate על כל qubit של הקידוד Hadamard gate הופך מצב אפס למצב פלוס ומצב אחד
למצב מינוס אז האפקט הכולל הוא שמקבלים את המצב שמוצג על המסך כאשר
פלוס פלוס פלוס ומינוס מינוס מינוס הם סימון מקוצר לטנזור של שלושה מצבי פלוס או שלושה מצבי
מינוס שגיאת היפוך פאזה או במילים אחרות Z gate הופך מצבי פלוס למצבי מינוס ומצבי מינוס ל
מצבי פלוס אז הקידוד הזה יהיה שימושי לזיהוי ותיקון שגיאות היפוך פאזה וכדי לעשות את זה אפשר
לשנות את circuit זיהוי השגיאות מקודם בדרך הבאה הנה ה-circuit מקודם ומה שנעשה הוא
פשוט לשים Hadamard gate-ים גם בהתחלה וגם בסוף כפי שמוצג על המסך
הרעיון מאוד פשוט שלושת ה-Hadamard gate-ים הראשונים הופכים מצבי פלוס ומינוס בחזרה למצבי אפס ואחד
אותן בדיקות זוגיות כמו קודם מתבצעות ואז השכבה השנייה של Hadamard gate-ים מחזירה אותנו ל
הקידוד שלנו דרך נוספת לחשוב על זה היא שבעצם מתרגמים שגיאות היפוך פאזה לשגיאות היפוך ביט על ידי צימוד עם פעולות
Hadamard אפשר אגב לפשט את ה-circuit קצת ה-circuit הזה כאן שקול לחלוטין
ואפשר לבדוק את זה בעצמכם אם בא לכם אז אם מכניסים את ה-qubit המקודד שלנו ל-circuit הזה בהנחה
שלא התרחשו שגיאות היפוך פאזה מקבלים סינדרום 00 שמצביע על כך שלא היו שגיאות היפוך
פאזה ואם כן יש שגיאת היפוך פאזה על ה-qubit העליון נגיד אז הפלוסים והמינוסים הימניים מתהפכים
וזה מוביל לסינדרום שגיאה שונה 01 במקרה הזה שמזהה את מיקום היפוך הפאזה בדיוק כמו
שהיה לנו עבור היפוך ביט ואז אפשר לתקן את זה על ידי הפעלת Z gate על ה-qubit העליון והמצב
דומה עבור שגיאות היפוך פאזה על כל אחד משני ה-qubit-ים האחרים אז אפשר בעצם לזהות ו
לתקן עד שגיאת היפוך פאזה אחת באמצעות הקוד הזה אבל לצערנו כפי שאולי ניחשתם עכשיו כבר אי אפשר
לתקן שגיאות היפוך ביט אבל לא הכל אבוד כי אפשר בעצם לשלב את שני הקודים
האלה יחד כדי לקבל קוד שיכול לתקן גם שגיאות היפוך ביט וגם שגיאות היפוך פאזה ובעצם הוא יוכל
לתקן כל שגיאה על qubit בודד עכשיו הגיע הזמן לדון בקוד ה-9 qubit של Shore שהוא קוד
קוונטי לתיקון שגיאות שאפשר לקבל על ידי שילוב יחד של שני הקודים שראינו עכשיו כלומר קוד החזרה של שלושה
ביטים שמאפשר לתקן שגיאת היפוך ביט בודדת והגרסה המשופרת של הקוד הזה שמאפשרת לתקן שגיאת היפוך פאזה
בודדת ליתר דיוק קוד ה-9 qubit של Shore הוא הקוד שמתקבל משרשור שני הקודים שפירושו
שקודם מפעילים קידוד אחד שמקודד qubit אחד לשלושה ואז מפעילים את הקידוד השני על כל אחד מ
שלושת ה-qubit-ים בנפרד אז נקבל תשעה qubit-ים בסך הכל אפשר לבטא את זה בצורת
דיאגרמת circuit כך קודם נפעיל את הגרסה המשופרת של קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים
שמזהה שגיאות היפוך פאזה ואז נקודד כל אחד מה-qubit-ים שמתקבלים בנפרד באמצעות קוד
החזרה של 3 ביטים המקורי אז אם מכווצים את ה-circuit הזה קצת כדי לפנות מקום אפשר
לתאר את הקוד במונחים קצת שונים על ידי תיאור איך שני מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי של ה-qubit המקורי
מקודדים וברגע שיודעים את זה אפשר לקבוע על ידי לינאריות איך וקטור מצב שרירותי של qubit
מקודד אז זה קוד ה-9 qubit של Shore והרעיון הוא שאחד הקודים מאפשר לתקן שגיאות היפוך
פאזה והקוד השני מאפשר לתקן שגיאות היפוך ביט וכפי שנראה זה בעצם אומר שאפשר
לתקן שגיאה שרירותית על qubit בודד עכשיו בואו נראה איך אפשר לזהות ולתקן שגיאות באמצעות קוד ה-9 qubit
של Shore נתחיל בשגיאות היפוך ביט שנקראות גם שגיאות X הנה ה-circuit שמבצע
את הקידוד וכדי שיהיה קל יותר לדבר על זה נחשוב על תשעת ה-qubit-ים שמתקבלים מהקוד הזה כמחולקים
לשלושה בלוקים של שלושה qubit-ים כאשר כל בלוק מייצג את הקידוד שמתקבל מהפעלת
שלב הקידוד השני שהוא קוד החזרה הרגיל של 3 ביטים שנקרא הקוד הפנימי ב
הקשר הזה בעוד שהקוד החיצוני הוא הקוד ששימש לשלב הקידוד הראשון שבמקרה הזה הוא הגרסה
המשופרת של קוד החזרה של שלושה ביטים שעובדת עבור שגיאות היפוך פאזה כדי לתקן שגיאות היפוך ביט אפשר
פשוט לטפל בכל אחד מהבלוקים בנפרד כל בלוק הוא קידוד של qubit באמצעות קוד החזרה של שלושה
ביטים והקוד הזה מגן מפני שגיאות היפוך ביט נניח קודם ששגיאת X מתרחשת על אחד מה-qubit-ים
כמו ה-qubit האמצעי בבלוק האמצעי אם בודקים באופן עצמאי כל אחד מהבלוקים לשגיאות היפוך ביט ו
מתקנים כל שגיאה שמוצאים אז השגיאה הזו תתוקן והקידוד המקורי ישוחזר
בעצם אפשר אפילו שיהיו מספר שגיאות X ועדיין לתקן אותן בדרך הזו בתנאי שהשגיאות נמצאות
בבלוקים נפרדים אם היו לנו שתיים או שלוש שגיאות X בבלוק בודד היינו בצרה אבל
כל עוד יש לכל היותר שגיאת X אחת לכל בלוק הקוד הפנימי יתפוס אותן ונוכל לשחזר את המצב המקודד
המקורי אז תיקון שגיאות היפוך ביט הוא עניין די פשוט בקוד הזה צריך גם לשקול שגיאות היפוך פאזה
או במילים אחרות שגיאות Z הפעם לא כל כך ברור מה צריך לעשות כי הקוד החיצוני הוא זה
שמתקן שגיאות היפוך פאזה אבל אי אפשר ישירות לזהות ולתקן אותן כי הקוד הפנימי איכשהו
מפריע אבל נראה איך לעשות את זה בקרוב כדי להבין טוב יותר איך שגיאות X ו-Z
עובדות ואיזה השפעות יש להן בתוך circuit-ים קוונטיים מועיל לשים לב לכמה יחסים פשוטים בין השגיאות האלה ל-
gate-ים מבוקרים NOT וזה גם יהיה מועיל בשיעור מאוחר יותר קודם נתחיל עם שגיאות X
או X gate-ים ואיך הם מתייחסים ל-gate-ים מבוקרים NOT אם מפעילים X gate על
qubit המטרה של gate מבוקר NOT ואז מפעילים את ה-gate המבוקר NOT אז זה שקול להחלפת הסדר ולבצע את ה-gate המבוקר NOT
קודם מצד שני אם מפעילים X gate על qubit הבקרה של gate מבוקר NOT ואז מפעילים את ה-gate המבוקר NOT אי אפשר פשוט
להחליף את הסדר אלא במקום זאת צריך להפעיל את ה-X gate על שני ה-qubit-ים ואפשר לבדוק את כל היחסים האלה
בעצמכם אם תרצו על ידי חשיבה על מה קורה למצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי למשל המצב דומה עבור שגיאות
Z חוץ מזה שהתפקידים של qubit הבקרה ו-qubit המטרה מתחלפים בפרט אם מבצעים
Z gate על qubit הבקרה של gate מבוקר NOT ואז מבצעים את ה-gate המבוקר NOT אז זה אותו אפקט כמו ביצוע
ה-Z gate אחרי ה-gate המבוקר NOT אבל אם מבצעים את ה-Z gate על qubit המטרה במקום אז זה
שקול לביצוע ה-gate המבוקר NOT קודם ואז הפעלת Z gate על שני ה-qubit-ים ולבסוף כל היחסים
האלה סימטריים במובן שתמיד אפשר להחליף את סדר ה-gate-ים בשני צדי כל משוואה
מה ששקול ללקיחת ההופכי או הצמוד ההרמיטי של שני הצדדים בהתחשב בכך ש-X ו-Z ו-gate מבוקר NOT
הם כולם ההופכיים של עצמם עכשיו בואו נשקול שגיאות היפוך פאזה ואיך אפשר לזהות ולתקן
אותן באמצעות קוד ה-9 qubit של Shore הנה circuit הקידוד שלנו ונמשיך לחשוב על תשעת
ה-qubit-ים שמשמשים בקידוד כמחולקים לשלושה בלוקים של שלושה qubit-ים נניח ששגיאת Z מתרחשת על
אחד מה-qubit-ים כמו זה שמסומן כאן באמצעות מה שראינו זה עתה לגבי Z
gate-ים ו-gate-ים מבוקרים NOT זה שקול לשתי שגיאות Z לפני ה-gate המבוקר NOT אחת על
הבקרה ואחת על qubit המטרה והשגיאות האלה במקרה מתחלפות עם ה-gate המבוקר NOT השני בבלוק אז
אפשר להחליף את הסדר והנה מה שמתקבל שגיאת ה-Z התחתונה לא עושה כלום כי היא פועלת על מצב
אפס ואפשר להחליק את כל השאר ולקבל את הדיאגרמה הזו אז מה שמצאנו הוא ששגיאת Z איפשהו בתוך
הבלוק האמצעי שקולה לשגיאת Z שמתרחשת על ה-qubit האמצעי לפני שלב הקידוד השני ו
אפשר לחשוב בדיוק אותו דבר לגבי שגיאת Z על כל אחד מה-qubit-ים היפוך פאזה על כל qubit בתוך בלוק
שקול להיפוך פאזה על ה-qubit המתאים לפני הקידוד הפנימי וזה בעצם די פשוט ואינטואיטיבי אם
חושבים על איך שגיאות Z משפיעות על קוד החזרה של שלושה ביטים אז אופציה אחת להתמודדות עם שגיאת
Z היא לפענח את הקוד הפנימי ואז לזהות ולתקן שגיאות Z באמצעות הקוד החיצוני שהוא הגרסה
המשופרת של קוד החזרה של 3 ביטים שיכולה לתקן שגיאת Z אז זה מתקן את שגיאת ה-Z שלנו ו
אפשר לקודד מחדש עם הקוד הפנימי אם רוצים לעשות את זה אפשר גם לתקן שגיאות Z
במקום כביכול בלי לפענח ולקודד מחדש וזה די פשוט אבל כדי להסביר איך אפשר
לעשות את זה נצטרך קצת יותר מקום נניח שמפענחים את הקוד הפנימי
ואז מחשבים את הסינדרום של הקוד החיצוני באמצעות אותה שיטה כמו קודם שבה מעורבים רק שלושת ה-qubit-ים מהקוד החיצוני ו
אז מקודדים מחדש אפשר לפשט את כל ה-gate-ים המבוקרים NOT האלה קצת ובעצם
אפשר להשתמש ביחסים בין NOT gate-ים ל-gate-ים מבוקרים NOT שראינו לפני כמה רגעים כדי לעזור עם
המשימה הזו ועל ידי כך אפשר לחסוך ארבעה gate-ים מבוקרים NOT וזה ה-circuit שמתקבל אם התרחשה שגיאת Z על אחד
מה-qubit-ים מה שהסינדרום אומר לנו עכשיו הוא לא איזה qubit חווה שגיאת Z אלא באיזה בלוק שגיאת ה-Z
התרחשה אבל זה בסדר כי אנחנו יודעים שלא משנה איזה qubit בתוך בלוק חווה שגיאת Z
האפקט זהה לכל שלושת ה-qubit-ים בתוך הבלוק ולכן אפשר בעצם לתקן את שגיאת ה-Z על ידי הפעלת Z gate על כל אחד
מה-qubit-ים בתוך הבלוק הזה זו אגב דוגמה למה שנקרא ניוון בקוד
לתיקון שגיאות שבו אנחנו לא מזהים באופן ייחודי שגיאה נתונה אבל אנחנו מסוגלים לתקן אותה בכל מקרה ולבסוף נניח ששתי
שגיאות מתרחשות גם היפוך ביט וגם היפוך פאזה אולי על אותו qubit למשל נניח ש
שגיאת היפוך ביט ושגיאת היפוך פאזה קורות על ה-qubit הזה ממש כפי שמסתבר השגיאות האלה ניתנות ל
זיהוי ותיקון באופן עצמאי לחלוטין ובעצם לא משנה אם מתקנים כל בלוק לשגיאת
היפוך ביט קודם ואז מתקנים היפוכי פאזה או אם עושים את זה בסדר ההפוך כדי לראות את זה בואו קודם נשים לב
שהסדר של השגיאות האלה לא משנה אז אפשר להפוך אותן אם רוצים הסיבה לכך היא לא שכי
X ו-Z מתחלפות כי הן לא X כפול Z שווה מינוס Z כפול X אבל
הגורם מינוס 1 לא משפיע במצב הזה כי הוא פאזה גלובלית אפשר עכשיו להזיז את שגיאת ה-Z בדיוק כמו
קודם ובשלב הזה ברור שאם קודם היינו מתקנים כל בלוק לשגיאות X ואז מתקנים
שגיאות Z אז היינו מתקנים את שתי השגיאות לחילופין אם מסיבה כלשהי
החלטנו לתקן שגיאות Z קודם היינו יכולים לעשות את זה ולשגיאת ה-X אין שום השפעה בתהליך הזה
וזה חייב להיות נכון כי ראשית שגיאת ה-X מתחלפת עם כל gate בודד ב-circuit שמחשב את
הסינדרום של הקוד החיצוני ושנית הסדר בין שגיאת ה-X ל-Z gate שמפעילים כדי לבצע את
התיקון לא משנה בדיוק כמו שטענו כשה-Z gate היה שגיאה אז זה מאפשר את תיקון שגיאת
ה-Z ואז אפשר לתקן כל בלוק כדי לסלק את שגיאת ה-X אז מה שהראנו הוא שאנחנו
יכולים לתקן שגיאת X שגיאת Z או שתיהן על כל אחד מה-qubit-ים באמצעות הקוד הזה
בעצם אפשר לתקן יותר שגיאות מזה כמו מספר שגיאות X כל עוד הן נופלות לבלוקים שונים
או מספר שגיאות Z כל עוד לכל היותר בלוק אחד מקבל מספר אי-זוגי שלהן אבל מכאן ואילך מה שיהיה הכי רלוונטי
הוא שאפשר לתקן שגיאת X שגיאת Z או שתיהן על כל qubit בודד ובחלק האחרון של השיעור
נראה איך זה מספיק בעצם כדי להסיק שהקוד הזה יכול לתקן שגיאה שרירותית על כל
qubit בודד לפני שנעבור לחלק האחרון של השיעור שבו נשקול שגיאות קוונטיות שרירותיות נשקול בקצרה
את הביצועים של קוד ה-9 qubit של Shore כאשר שגיאות המיוצגות על ידי מטריצות פאולי מתרחשות באקראי על
ה-qubit-ים ליתר דיוק בואו נשקול מודל רעש פשוט שבו שגיאות מתרחשות באופן בלתי תלוי על ה-qubit-ים
כאשר כל qubit חווה שגיאה עם הסתברות P וללא מתאם בין שגיאות על qubit-ים
שונים המקרה הגרוע ביותר עבור קוד ה-9 qubit של Shore הוא ששגיאת Y או במילים אחרות גם שגיאת X וגם שגיאת Z
מתרחשת על כל qubit מושפע ונניח את המקרה הגרוע ביותר הזה רק לצורך קבלת חסם
על ביצועי הקוד אבל אפשר גם לשקול למשל ששלוש שגיאות פאולי הן בעלות הסתברות
שווה עכשיו נניח ש-Q הוא qubit במצב מסוים שאנחנו רוצים להגן עליו מפני שגיאות ודמיינו שיש
לנו את האפשרות להשתמש בקוד ה-9 qubit של Shore האם כדאי להשתמש בו ובכן התשובה היא לא בהכרח
כן כי אם יש יותר מדי רעש או במילים אחרות P גדול מדי השימוש בקוד Shore בעצם יכול להחמיר
את המצב בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו עם קוד החזרה כש-P גדול מ-1/2 אבל אם P קטן מספיק אז
התשובה היא כן כדאי להשתמש בקוד אז בואו נראה למה זה ככה ומה זה אומר ש-P גדול מדי או קטן
מספיק עבור הקוד הזה קוד Shore יכול לתקן כל שגיאת פאולי על qubit בודד ובמקרה
הגרוע ביותר שבו שגיאות פאולי הן שגיאות Y זה אומר שהקוד מגן בהצלחה על Q עם הסתברות שנתונה על ידי
הביטוי שמוצג על המסך במיוחד הקוד עובד כשאין שגיאות וזה קורה
עם הסתברות 1 מינוס P בחזקת 9 כי יש תשעה qubit-ים שכל אחד מהם חייב להיות לא מושפע והוא עובד כשיש
בדיוק שגיאה אחת ובהתחשב בכך שיש תשעה qubit-ים שונים שיכולים להיות מושפעים זה קורה עם הסתברות 9 כפול P כפול 1 מינוס P בחזקת 8
מצד שני אם לא היינו מתאמצים להשתמש בקוד ה-qubit היחיד שלנו לא היה מושפע משגיאה עם
הסתברות 1 מינוס P אז הקוד עוזר רק כשההסתברות הראשונה גדולה מהשנייה
כי הביטויים האלה מייצגים את ההסתברויות שלנו להצלחה בשני המקרים כשמשתמשים בקוד וכש
לא הנה גרף של שתי הפונקציות האלה עבור ערכים קטנים של P ומגלים שנקודת האיזון מתרחשת ב
בערך 3 ורבע אחוז אז אם P קטן מהערך הזה אז הקוד
עוזר בנקודת האיזון ההסתברויות שוות אז אנחנו סתם מבזבזים זמן יחד עם 8 qubit-ים אם
משתמשים בקוד אבל מלבד זאת אין נזק ומעבר לנקודה הזו בהחלט לא כדאי להשתמש בקוד הזה
כי הוא בעצם מגדיל את הסיכוי לשגיאה על ה-qubit המקודד שאותו אנחנו בדרך כלל מכנים
qubit לוגי בהקשר הזה וזה קורה פשוט כי הסיכוי לשתי שגיאות או יותר על תשעה qubit-ים הוא
גדול מהסיכוי לשגיאה אחת על qubit בודד עבור ערכי P בטווח הזה 3 ורבע אחוז אולי לא נשמע
טוב במיוחד בהשוואה ל-50% שזו נקודת האיזון האנלוגית עבור קוד החזרה של שלושה ביטים עבור
מידע קלאסי אבל קשה יותר להגן על מידע קוונטי ויתרה מכך למרות שהקוד
הזה מייצג תגלית מבריקה בתור הקוד הקוונטי הראשון לתיקון שגיאות והוא נהדר למטרות פדגוגיות העובדה
היא שהוא פשוט לא כל כך טוב כקוד במונחים מעשיים עד כה שקלנו שגיאות X
ושגיאות Z בהקשר של קוד ה-9 qubit של Shore עכשיו בואו נשקול שגיאות שרירותיות
נתחיל קודם בשגיאות יוניטריות אז למשל שגיאה כזו יכולה להתאים לסיבוב קטן מאוד
של כדור Bloch שאולי מייצג שגיאה שנגרמת על ידי gate לא מושלם למשל
או שזו יכולה להיות כל פעולה יוניטרית אחרת על qubit ולא בהכרח משהו קרוב לפעולת
הזהות זה עשוי להיראות כאילו תיקון שגיאות כאלה קשה יש אינסוף שגיאות אפשריות
כאלה ואי אפשר לדמיין שנוכל איכשהו לזהות בדיוק מה השגיאה ואז לבטל אותה אבל אנחנו
בעצם לא צריכים לעשות שום דבר שונה ממה שכבר דנו בו כל עוד אנחנו יכולים לתקן היפוך ביט היפוך פאזה או שניהם אז אנחנו
בעצם נצליח לתקן שגיאה יוניטרית שרירותית על qubit בודד ואסביר עכשיו למה זה
ככה קודם כל כמו כל מטריצות 2 על 2 אפשר לבטא מטריצה יוניטרית שרירותית
שמייצגת שגיאה על qubit בודד כצירוף לינארי של ארבע מטריצות פאולי כולל מטריצת
הזהות ואגב כפי שאולי שמתם לב אני משתמש ב-X Y ו-Z גדולות לסימון מטריצות פאולי שאינן זהות
ואמשיך לעשות את זה לשארית הסדרה הזו זה מקובל בתיקון שגיאות קוונטי וזה גם הופך
דברים לקצת יותר קלים לקריאה בהקשר הזה גם יהיה נוח להשתמש באינדקסים כדי לציין על איזה
qubit פעולה יוניטרית נתונה על qubit פועלת אז למשל אם משתמשים במוסכמת
מספור ה-qubit-ים של Qiskit שמתחילה מ-qubit אפס מימין אז יש לנו את הביטויים שמוצגים על המסך עבור
פעולות יוניטריות שונות על qubit-ים בודדים כאשר בכל מקרה עושים טנזור של המטריצה היוניטרית עם מטריצת הזהות
על כל qubit אחר אז בפרט אפשר לבטא U על qubit K כאותו
צירוף לינארי כמו קודם חוץ מזה שכל מטריצת פאולי מופעלת על qubit K לא צריך להתעסק עם
האינדקס של הזהות אגב ההבנה כאן היא שזו הזהות על כל
ה-qubit-ים עכשיו נניח ש-psi הוא הקידוד של 9 qubit-ים של מצב qubit אם השגיאה U קורית
ל-qubit K אז מתקבל U על K כפול psi שאפשר לבטא כצירוף לינארי של פעולות פאולי על psi שזה
כמובן פשוט psi במקרה של הזהות בנקודה הזו מועיל לשים לב שמטריצת פאולי
Y שווה ל-i כפול X כפול Z אז אפשר לבצע את ההחלפה הזו
בביטוי שלנו אז השגיאה הזו התרחשה ועכשיו נניח שאנחנו מנסים לתקן אותה באמצעות אותו הליך כמו
קודם הצעד הראשון הוא לחשב את הסינדרום שבמקרה של קוד Shore הוא באורך 8 ביטים שני ביטים עבור כל אחד מ
שלוש הפעמים שמשתמשים בקוד הפנימי בתוספת שני ביטים נוספים עבור הקוד החיצוני אבל זה לא ממש משנה אפשר פשוט לחשוב על זה כ
מחרוזת באורך קבוע כלשהו הנה תיאור של המצב שמתקבל ממש לפני מדידת הסינדרום כאשר כל
סינדרום הוא איזה שמונה ביטים שמתקבלים משגיאת הפאולי המתאימה שימו לב בשלב הזה ששתי
המערכות מתואמות באופן כללי וזה בעצם המפתח לכל העניין על ידי מדידת הסינדרום מה
שנעשה בפועל הוא לקרוס את המצב למצב שבו אחת מארבע פעולות הפאולי הופעלה על
ה-qubit ה-K של psi ונדע מהסינדרום איזו פעולת פאולי הייתה אז נוכל לתקן אם
צריך בפרט אם מודדים את הסינדרום ומבצעים את התיקון המתאים אז מתקבל מצב של
הצורה שמוצגת על המסך שבאופן קריטי הוא מצב מכפלה יש לנו את הקידוד המקורי הלא פגום כ
גורם הטנזור הימני שזה מה שהכי חשוב כאן ומשמאל יש לנו מטריצת צפיפות S ש
מתארת סינדרום שגיאה אקראי אבל אין יותר מתאם עם המערכת שאכפת לנו ממנה שהיא
זו שמימין כי השגיאות תוקנו בשלב הזה אפשר לזרוק את qubit-י הסינדרום או לאפס אותם ב
מקרה שנרצה להשתמש בהם שוב וזה בעצם די חשוב כי ככה האקראיות או האנטרופיה
שנוצרת על ידי שגיאות מוסרת מהמערכת וככה הדיסקרטיזציה של שגיאות עובדת לפחות עבור שגיאות
יוניטריות בעיקרון על ידי מדידת הסינדרום אנחנו למעשה מקרינים את השגיאה על שגיאה שמתוארת על ידי
מטריצת פאולי במבט ראשון זה עשוי להיראות טוב מכדי להיות אמיתי שאפשר לתקן שגיאות יוניטריות שרירותיות
ככה אפילו שגיאות שהן זעירות וכמעט לא מורגשות בפני עצמן אבל מה שחשוב להבין כאן
הוא שזו שגיאה יוניטרית על qubit בודד ובעיצוב של הקוד פעולה על qubit בודד לא יכולה לשנות
את המצב של ה-qubit הלוגי שמקודד כל מה שהיא יכולה לעשות הוא להזיז את המצב מחוץ למרחב של קידודים
תקפים אבל אז התיקונים מחזירים אותו בדיוק למקום שהיה בו ולבסוף בואו נשקול מה קורה
כאשר מתרחשת שגיאה שרירותית לא בהכרח יוניטרית ההגדרה זהה לקודם
קידדנו qubit אחד ל-9 באמצעות קוד Shore ושגיאה שרירותית כלשהי המיוצגת על ידי ערוץ qubit פי
מתרחשת על אחד מה-qubit-ים כפי שנראה הכל מסתדר בערך באותו אופן
כמו שהיה עבור שגיאות יוניטריות והצעד הראשון לאימות זה הוא לשקול ייצוג Kraus של
השגיאה שלנו מה שאפשר לעשות עכשיו הוא לעקוב אחרי בדיוק אותו היגיון כמו עבור שגיאות יוניטריות חוץ מזה שמפעילים את
ההיגיון הזה על מטריצות Kraus ולא על מטריצה יוניטרית בודדת שמייצגת שגיאה
בפרט כל מטריצת Kraus ניתנת לביטוי כצירוף לינארי של מטריצות פאולי וזה מאפשר לנו
לבטא את הפעולה של השגיאה פי על כל qubit K שעליו היא מתרחשת בצורה שמוצגת כאן על
המסך כל מה שאנחנו עושים כאן בעצם הוא לפרוש את מטריצות Kraus כצירופים לינאריים של מטריצות
פאולי אם אז מחשבים ומודדים את סינדרום השגיאה ומתקנים כל שגיאה שמתגלה נקבל
מצב דומה למה שהיה במקרה של שגיאה יוניטרית לא אכנס לפרטים הכל די דומה למקרה
היוניטרי וגם קצת יותר מבולגן לכתוב אבל מבחינה מושגית זה די
פשוט כדאי לציין שכל זה מוכלל לקודים קוונטיים אחרים לתיקון שגיאות כולל קודים שיכולים לתקן שגיאות על מספר
qubit-ים במקרה כזה שגיאות על מספר qubit-ים ניתנות לביטוי כצירופים לינאריים של מכפלות טנזור של מטריצות
פאולי ובהתאם הסינדרומים השונים האפשריים יתארו תיקונים שמבוצעים על מספר qubit-ים ולא רק אחד
אבל הרעיון הבסיסי הוא בדיוק אותו דבר שוב על ידי מדידת הסינדרום
אנחנו למעשה מקרינים או קורסים שגיאות לקבוצה דיסקרטית של אפשרויות המיוצגות על ידי מכפלות טנזור
של מטריצות פאולי ועל ידי תיקון השגיאות האלה כלומר שגיאות הפאולי אנחנו יכולים לשחזר את המצב
המקודד המקורי בינתיים כל האקראיות שנוצרת בתהליך מועברת ל-qubit-י הסינדרום שאפשר אז
לזרוק או לאפס וזה קריטי כי ככה האנטרופיה שנוצרת על ידי שגיאות ומדידות סינדרום
מוסרת מהמערכת וזה סוף השיעור שבו לקחנו מבט ראשון על
תיקון שגיאות קוונטי כולל קוד ה-9 qubit של Shore ודיסקרטיזציה של שגיאות אני מקווה שתצטרפו אלי ל
שיעור הבא שבו נדון בפורמליזם המייצב שמספק לנו כלי רב עוצמה לתיאור ו
ניתוח מחלקה גדולה ומעניינת של קודים קוונטיים לתיקון שגיאות כולל כאלה שהם מועמדים מבטיחים ל
מחשבים קוונטיים אמיתיים להתראות עד אז